et on retrouve à kiev notre
correspondant gulliver craag et bulgares
gulliver vous avez suivi le point presse
des autorités ukrainiennes quelles sont
les évolutions sur le terrain l'armée
russe semble ne pas avoir opéré de
retrait
alors le porte parole des militaires
ukrainien dit qu' une partie de l'armée
russe a s'est retiré et aurait même
retraverser la frontière biélorusse et
risque mais selon lui c'est pour se
regrouper pour se remettre en ordre de
bataille après des pertes face au contre
offensive ukrainienne et selon lui ce
serait pour préparer de nouvelles
offensives il a dit que les autorités
ukrainiennes ne crois pas du tout aux
déclarations des rues ce qu'on croit
comme quoi il se concentrerait
maintenant uniquement sur le dôme basse
et il pense que l'encerclement de kiev
où la tentative d'encercler kiev où
d'autres grandes villes comme archive
est encore une réelle possibilité mais
ce n'est pas pour tout de suite pour le
moment il est vrai selon ce porte parole
des militaires ukrainien que les
opérations offensives risques sont
concentrées effectivement dans le dos ne
passe il a dit que des batailles très
intenses ont lieu en ce moment notamment
les forces russes est entre est de
prendre la ville d'un robinet qui est
dans la région de louhans ce que plus au
nord il ya aussi bien sûr marioupol qui
selon ce porte-parole militaire n'est
toujours pas tombée aux mains des russes
même si la ville a été très
substantiellement détruite mais ce qui
est intéressant c'est qu'il y a des
banlieues de donetsk donetsk qui est au
contrôle des forces pro russes a soutenu
plus tôt par là par la russie depuis
2014 il y a des banlieues de donetsk où
des villes satellites qui était resté au
contrôle des ukrainiens à venir qu'à et
marin cas selon les militaires ukrainien
ces villes résistent encore ne sont pas
tombés au ruf malgré une offensive très
déterminé et des batailles très intense
dans ces localités de l'hiver on apprend
aussi que le procureur général a lancé
une procédure à l'encontre de la russie
pour crimes contre l'humanité
oui je ne sais pas s'ils ont déjà lancé
la procédure mais ils ont l'intention de
le faire ça c'est sûr l'ukraine a
ouvert de nombreux cas pour des crimes
de guerre qui peut aller des
bombardements de zones civiles au
meurtre de civils l'ukrainien dans des
villages et des villes qui ont été
occupées par les russes aussi des crimes
sexuels dont des villes et les villages
occupés il ya toutes sortes de crimes de
guerre contre lesquels l'ukraine a déjà
ouvert des procédures et la procureure
générale et rennes avaient n'édicte nova
a dit que l'ukraine étudié aussi la
possibilité de d'accuser la russie
formellement de crimes contre l'humanité
ce serait les crimes de génocide et cela
toucherait le bombardement de marioupol
qui selon les ukrainiens visait vraiment
l'anéantissement des d'un maximum de
civils dans marioupol parce qu'il semble
vraiment qu'il y avait un bombardement
complètement indiscriminé de cette ville
merci beaucoup au but les verts craag je
rappelle que vous êtes à café que vous
suivez pour nous cette invasion russe